Ein ganz normaler Samstagmorgen bei
Familie Geyer in Berlin.
Die Eltern freuen sich auf ein
gemeinsames Frühstück.
Die beiden Söhne und deren Cousine
beschäftigen sich mit ihren Smartphones.
Seit sie neun Jahre alt sind,
besitzen sie eigene Geräte.
Man hat so ‘n bisschen Kontrollverlust.
[Ein] latent schlechtes Gewissen, wenn
man irgendetwas zulässt, hab‘ ich schon.
Wenn ich mir denke: Oh Gott, oh Gott,
nachher guckt er da was
ganz Fürchterliches,
was überhaupt nicht für
(für, für, für) ihn gedacht ist.
Für Oscar, Matilda und Gustav
sind Smartphones das wichtigste Medium.
Und Messengerdienste wie WhatsApp
sind die häufigsten Anwendungen:
70 Prozent der deutschen Kinder
kommunizieren so am liebsten
mit ihren Freunden.
50 Prozent nutzen Spiele-Apps oder
soziale Netzwerke wie Instagram.
Wer kein Smartphone hat,
kann nicht mitreden.
Weil es viele hatten und ich halt beeindruckt
war, was man damit alles machen kann.
Wir haben auch ‘n Klassen-Chat, und
da wird halt viel drin geschrieben,
obwohl es auch nervig ist, weil
nachts geht’s halt durchgehend.
Und da muss man halt auch auf
Flugmodus schalten, aber,
ja, das benutze ich am häufigsten.
Für den Neun- und die Zwölfjährigen
gilt nur eine eiserne Regel:
Beim Essen bleiben die
Smartphones außen vor.
Darüber hinaus gibt es keine
festen Vereinbarungen.
Jeden Tag wird neu verhandelt, wie lange
sie digitale Medien nutzen dürfen.
Da geht‘s mir auch drum, dass man
Alternativen anbietet und vorlebt,
dass man rausgeht und was unternimmt.
Das heißt, die haben noch andere
Interessen und Vorstellungen,
was man so mit seiner
Zeit machen kann.
Und wenn sie dann nach ‘nem langen Tag
draußen oder nach [dem] Fußballtraining
oder so was, abends so ‘n
bisschen kontemplieren
mit dem (mit dem) Handy in der Hand,
finde ich das auch okay.
Eine häufige Sorge der Eltern: Die Kinder
würden Konzentrationsstörungen bekommen,
wenn sie zu lange digitale Angebote nutzen.
Sarah Lange kennt die Bedenken.
Sie berät Eltern und Lehrer zum
Thema Medienkonsum von Kindern.
Ihre Beobachtung: Smartphones
können auch hilfreich sein.
Das sieht man häufig, wenn man Projekte
mit Kindern und Jugendlichen durchführt,
dass Medien da große Ziele, große
Erfolge verbuchen können,
wenn zum Beispiel Kinder, die
Aufmerksamkeitsschwäche haben,
sich dann tatsächlich mal auf etwas
konzentrieren in dem Projekt.
Familie Geyer hat keine Jugendschutz-
Software auf ihrem Computer aktiviert
– weder bei Spielen noch beim Surfen.
Die Kinder sollen eigenständig
den sinnvollen Umgang
mit Internet-Inhalten lernen.
Wichtig ist, hinterher darüber zu sprechen
und Grenzen gemeinsam zu setzen:
Dazu raten auch Experten.
Das ist ganz wichtig, dass in Familien
ein gutes Verhältnis herrscht,
wo man mit Problemen, mit Ängsten,
mit Sorgen aufeinander zugehen kann.
Und dafür ist es ganz wichtig, Kinder
und Jugendliche zu verstehen
und sie auch in ihrer
Mediennutzung zu verstehen.
Das fällt vielen Eltern nicht leicht.
Für Kinder und Jugendliche verschwimmen
Offline- und Online-Welten.
Wie beim Spiel „Pokémon Go“.
Bei Spielen, Chats und Apps
sind sie ihren Eltern oft voraus.
Allerdings: Manche
Anwendungen nutzt inzwischen
die gesamte Familie
wie selbstverständlich:
Hallo.
Hallo Oscar, hier ist Mama.
Wo seid ihr denn?
So ist es heute viel einfacher, in Kontakt
zu bleiben: dank der Smartphones.
Das ist halt die Kulturtechnik.
Wenn man da nicht Bescheid weiß und
damit umgehen kann und da flink ist,
weil die Eltern bildungsbürgerlicherweise
einen die ganze Zeit nur gezwungen haben,
Bücher zu lesen, dann kann‘s
auch schwierig werden,
wenn man später mal einen
Job finden will, oder.
Und deswegen finde ich Verhindern
irgendwie Blödsinn,
aber man muss das so ein bisschen
bewusst begleiten und gucken,
dass das nicht aus ‘m Ruder läuft.
Digitale Medien haben
die Familien erobert.